This is a super interesting story.
On Monday, I played for you a clip of Fox
news propagandists Tucker Carlson's program
where he was against the assassination by
Donald Trump of the Uranian codes leader,
Kaseem Sola Moni, and I said during that segment,
Tucker Carlson is against against the assassination,
which is good, but he's against it for the
wrong reasons.
For example, Tucker Carlson said, we have
domestic issues to focus on, not we shouldn't
be assassinating Iranian leaders in Iraq.
Now I agree with that.
The problem is that the domestic issues he
wants to focus on are the wrong ones.
Like for example, uh, the fact that he believes
immigrants make the country dirtier, including
Brown immigrants from Latin America.
I agree with Tucker.
The assassination was bad.
I don't agree with Tucker on the domestic
issues he wants to focus on now, I also said
on Monday, even if talker is against the assassination
for the wrong reasons, if he pierces the echo
chamber of some Fox news viewers, it's still
a good thing to have him on Fox news saying
he's against what Donald Trump did any run.
It appears that Tucker may have pierced the
echo chamber of Donald Trump himself.
There's a new report in Buzzfeed news that
Donald Trump has been watching the Fox news
coverage about what he's been doing in Iran
and that he appears to have been influenced
by a Tucker Carlson straight up saying he's
against this Sean Hannity sort of still sucking
up to Trump, but I believe saying that he
wouldn't be in favor of boots on the ground
and Iran.
So this is one of those curb your enthusiasm
moments where the camera slowly, uh, zooms
in on Larry David doing the, on the one hand,
on the other hand thing, on the one hand,
it's terrible that Fox news actually influences
presidential policy.
We know Trump watches Tucker Hannity talks
to Hannity, directly watches Fox and friends.
It's a peanut gallery influencing presidential
policy and that's terrible.
On the other hand, if Trump watching Fox made
him less interested in war with Iran, then
we kind of have to be happy with that, at
least to some degree.
Here's a reminder of what Tucker Carlson said,
uh, on the late last week, early this week,
which we talked about on Monday,
threats in the region.
If you don't live in Washington, here's the
translation that would be in hostile middle
Eastern countries, places where American troops
would never be in the first place were it
not for the insistent demands of non geniuses
like max boot and John Bolton.
But nevermind.
No one in Washington is in mood for big picture
questions right now.
Questions the obvious ones like, is Iran really
the greatest threat we face and who's actually
benefiting from this and why are we continuing
to ignore the decline of our own country in
favor of jumping into another quagmire from
which there was no obvious exit.
By the way, if we're still in Afghanistan,
19 years sad years later, what makes us think
there's a quick way out of Iran and so on?
Nobody thinking like that right now.
Instead, chest beaters like Senator Ben Sasse
of Nebraska are making unusual warlike noises.
The ones they always make.
This is very simple.
Ben Sasse wrote in a statement last night,
general Soleimani is dead because he was an
evil bastard who murdered Americans, which
is essentially true.
So Amani was certainly a bad guy, but does
that make killing him?
Quote, very simple.
It does not nothing about life, and certainly
nothing about killing is ever very simple.
And any politician who tells you otherwise
is dumb or is lying.
Yes, Solemani was linked to the deaths of
Americans.
Nobody mourns his passing.
But Mexico and China are also linked to the
deaths of Americans.
Each has flooded our country with narcotics
from which tens of thousands of Americans
die every single year.
Not that anyone in power cares.
So does that mean we get to bomb Wahaca?
Can we start assassinating generals and the
people's liberation army?
Now, there's another interpretation here that
suggests Trump may be getting foreign policy
advice from Fox is better than the alternative.
And this might sound absolutely crazy.
Is it possible that the advice Trump would
get from Fox news is less radical than what
he would get from the people in his administration?
So I'll give you a very specific, tangible
example.
Tucker Carlson is horrible, but he has an
anti intervention is streak.
He doesn't seem bloodthirsty to go to war
with whoever he can.
Maybe we're better off with Trump listening
more to Tucker and less to, for example, Stephen
Miller, who is an absolutely unhinged radical.
I'm thinking out loud here and this may be
totally misguided in a perfect world, in an
even remotely reasonable world, Fox news would
not be influencing presidential policy, but
as a sort of Sophie's choice situation, if
you ask me, do I want Stephen Miller guiding
Donald Trump's foreign policy or do I want
Tucker Carlson guiding Trump's foreign policy?
Maybe Tucker Carlson is the preference.
As horrible as he is, this is not a normal
conversation.
This is not something we would normally think
about in a normal administration.
We might be saying, which school of economic
thought would we prefer the president's domestic
policy be based on under Trump we're saying
would we rather Trump get foreign policy ideas
from xenophobe propagandists, Tucker Carlson
or radical white nationalists, Stephen Miller,
still between two bad choices there can be
a less bad one.
The 2016 election is certainly evidence of
that.
The country made the wrong choice there and
maybe I prefer Trump getting foreign policy
advice from anti intervention is Tucker Carlson.
Then from that absolute whacked out advisor,
Stephen Miller, let me know what you think.